Prügeleien im Supermarkt,
Pöbeleien in öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln:
Ich sehe immer mehr solcher
Videos in den sozialen Medien
und erlebe sogar Auseinandersetzungen
auf der Straße.
Deshalb frage ich Konflikt-Expertin Katty
Nöllenburg: Warum passiert das?
Also, wir erleben ja momentan eine
gesamtgesellschaftliche Anspannung
einfach dadurch, dass wir alle von
den Corona-Maßnahmen oder auch
einer Angst vor Corona – je nachdem,
was einen mehr stresst – beeinflusst sind.
Also, das heißt, alle Konflikte, die es
normalerweise auch gibt im Alltag,
sind erst mal mit einer Schicht Stress
quasi etwas noch mehr belegt.
Auch ich habe das Gefühl, dass viele
Menschen gestresster sind,
besonders in Supermärkten
und öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln.
Ob das wirklich an Corona liegt,
kann man aber schwer feststellen,
sagt die Berliner Polizeigewerkschaft.
Und soziale Medien können unsere
Wahrnehmung auch verzerren.
Die Anzeigen wegen Beleidigung jedenfalls
sind in Berlin im Vergleich zum letzten Jahr
um zehn Prozent gestiegen, sagt die Polizei.
Die Konflikte, die ich erlebe, drehen sich
zum Beispiel um das Tragen von Masken.
Maria Almeida, eine in Berlin
lebende Brasilianerin,
wurde von einer Frau ohne
Maske im Zug belästigt.
Ich habe sie zweimal höflich gebeten,
vielleicht einfach woandershin zu gehen
und woandershin zu sprechen.
Das hat sie nicht gemacht und war
mir gegenüber sehr aggressiv,
weil ich eine Maske getragen habe.
Ich bin aufgestanden und weggegangen.
Ich habe mich sehr unwohl gefühlt
und hatte ein bisschen Angst.
In meinem Umfeld finden manche, dass die
Stimmung aggressiver geworden ist,
andere aber nicht.
Ich frage mich, ob Leute, die
wegen ihres Jobs jeden Tag
mit vielen anderen Menschen zu
tun haben, stärker betroffen sind.
Wir treffen Imke Zimmermann,
eine Kassiererin,
die bei ihrer täglichen Arbeit
Aggression erlebt.
Es gibt aber auch wirklich Personen,
die schon reinkamen und wirklich
gesagt haben:
„Nein, ich trage keine Maske.“
Also, da erinnere ich mich auch an einen Fall.
Und dann haben wir halt gesagt:
„Na gut, dann können Sie leider
nicht einkaufen gehen.“
Dann ist er halt richtig aggressiv geworden.
Und gerade die, die an der Kasse sitzen,
was ich auch am meisten mache,
waren halt diejenigen, die das wirklich auch
die ganze Zeit abbekommen haben.
Am liebsten hätte sie auch für ein oder zwei
Wochen von zu Hause gearbeitet,
erzählt Imke – um mal durchzuatmen.
Ja, also persönlich war es einen Tag so:
Da saß ich halt an der Kasse und da
gab es halt wirklich einen Moment,
wo ich so mehrere Kunden hintereinander
hatte, die mich halt angemeckert haben,
angeschrien haben, und dann kam halt
ein Kollege und er hat gefragt,
ob alles okay ist, und ich hatte dann wirklich
… da ist bei mir dann so ’n bisschen alles …
die Welt zusammengebrochen.
Die Hälfte aller Deutschen fühlt sich durch
Corona gestresst, heißt es in einer Umfrage.
Und dieser Stress offenbart die Gräben
in unserer Gesellschaft.
Es gab schon immer Bevölkerungsgruppen,
die gefährdeter waren,
angefeindet zu werden im öffentlichen Raum.
Es ist grundlegend so,
dass sich Frauen immer –
verallgemeinernd gesagt –
ungeschützter gefühlt haben im öffentlichen
Raum als Männer.
Es war immer so, dass schwarze Menschen
oder People of Color gefährdeter waren,
angefeindet zu werden, als weiße Menschen
im öffentlichen Raum.
Das hat Mandy erlebt;
sie will anonym bleiben.
Die Leute sind wütend, weil sie während des
Lockdowns daheim eingesperrt sind,
und suchen jetzt einen
Schuldigen und sagen:
„China ist schuld, wegen den Chinesen
passiert das alles.“
Und weil andere Asiaten in ihren
Augen auch wie Chinesen aussehen,
werden wir alle dafür verantwortlich gemacht.
Mittlerweile will Mandy auf der Straße
verbergen, dass sie Asiatin ist.
In Zeiten von Corona trifft Aggression
oft die Schwächsten.
Ich hoffe, dass sich das mit der Lockerung
der Restriktionen ändert
und dass solche Videos nicht mehr
allzu lange in meiner Timeline auftauchen.